Registration is only open
during certain periods of time.
So, before you go to register,
you should check to see when
you're allowed to register.
To do this, first click
Student Services & Financial Aid, and
then click Registration.
This will take you to
the Registration menu.
>From here, click Registration Status,
then choose which term to check.
Here, you'll be shown during
which times you can register.
There are two phases to registration.
Phase one, a couple of months before
the semester starts, and phase two,
right at the beginning of the semester.
You'll get a time ticket for each.
Here you'll also see if you
have any holds on your account.
A hold will prevent
you from registering.
If you see any holds, contact the
registrar's office for more information.